all right it's been a while since we've
done hatred mail because of the vacation
and the Bendixon guest hosting schedule
and so on and so forth but finally today
from Las Vegas it is time to get back to
hatred mail because it's God's divine
plan that every child be born but an act
of patriotic duty to snuff that bastard
if he sets a foot near your stuff
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom so I've told you that
there are many people who love love that
the David Pakman show
is in the midst of a financial hardship
as a result of the YouTube advertiser
boycott and this hatred mail is about
that this is a hatred who loves the fact
that as a result of the YouTube ad
boycott our revenue has been cut 40 to
50 percent and is relishing the
possibility in their mind that we might
go off the air take a listen to this uh
David is going to have to find a real
job he is a greedy sleazeball Lolich
suck it's get a real job David fake news
crack man why don't you talk about what
that Kenyan creep did to America or
better yet jackass talk about that
creepy Hilary selling 20% of our uranium
to Russia you suck Trump is the greatest
president we have ever had so there's a
few different things here one is this
idea of a real job up at what point is
it fair to say that I have a real job I
mean we've got a business with staff and
uh you know affiliates that are relying
on us for content I don't know I don't
know if that'll ever go away but yes ok
someday maybe I'll have to get a quote
real job but the real issue is that
people who see the show as a threat to
the narrative they'd like to be out
there perpetuating fall
beliefs and insane Trump logic would
love it for the David Pakman show to go
off the air and we're doing everything
we can to prevent having to change
anything that we're doing okay so you
can use the coupon code hey tree at 40
to get a 14% 40% discount off of
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership you can also contribute at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
that's another way to fight people like
this guy who wants us to go off the air
as a result of the YouTube ad boycott
you can also get david pakman show
coffee bumper stickers and apparel at
david pakman.com slash gear all of that
stuff helps the show ok